There are more humans trapped in slavery
today than any other time in history.
It makes you think,
Why the media, most of them,
and also some people in Hollywood,
do not want to talk about this.
More than one in five victims
of sex trafficking are children.
By some estimates, 4.8 million people are trapped
or forced into sexual exploitation globally.
Ask yourself - why don't they want us to see it?
What are they hiding?
This video is going to open
your eyes to the truth.
What you need to do is decide whether you want
to live in the truth or in a made-up false world,
where evil controls what you think and believe.
Let me give you an example.
The movie the "Sound of Freedom"
is an amazing film by Angel Studios and is
based on a true story of child sex trafficking.
It's about Tim Ballard, a federal agent
played by Jim Caviezel, who decided to quit
his job and leave his pension in order to save
innocent little children used as sex slaves.
Now, after you've watched this powerful amazing
movie, it gives you the following facts.
There are more humans trapped in slavery
today than any other time in history.
Including when slavery was legal.
Millions of these slaves are children.
Human trafficking is a hundred and fifty
billion dollar a year industry.
This is insane.
Just so you have an idea of
how big an industry this is,
Coca-Cola, they're across the whole globe, right?
They only have around 40 billion a year.
That's how much they make.
And then when you look at McDonald's,
they have around 20 billion a year. 150 billion
industry that is trafficking, and the US is one
of the top destinations for human trafficking
and is among the largest consumers of child sex.
This is sickening.
The US is one of the top destinations
in the world for trafficking?
It makes you think,
why the media, most of them, and also some people
in Hollywood, do not want to talk about this.
And if they do, they're negative about this.
They want to discredit this movie.
Why?
Ask yourself.
Because no rational human being with good
values, good morals, will be against this.
Unless they agree with what is happening.
They want it to happen.
And they themselves are hiding something.
Watch this.
These films are created out of moral panics.
They're created out of bogus statistics.
They're created out of fear and with
something like the Sound of Freedom,
it specifically is looking at QAnon
concepts of these child trafficking rings
that are run by the high level elites.
Here's how the media received
it at the Washington Post.
Sound of Freedom as a box office
hit, whose star embraces QAnon.
Rolling Stone: Sound of Freedom is a
superhero movie for dads with brain
worms. The Guardian: Sound of Freedom, the
QAnon adjacent thriller seducing America.
For some reason, the entire media is smearing
this movie as a dangerous conspiracy theory.
The press is saying that the star,
Jim Caviezel, is a QAnon guy.
And Jim plays Tim Ballard, which is strange
because just a few years ago the same media was
celebrating Tim Ballard's heroics.
Watch.
Tim Ballard has one mission -
to track down child traffickers.
Four months ago, Colombian authorities
asked him to investigate a tip that
children were being sold there as sex slaves.
Within a half hour, this individual walks up to
me, starts asking me what I'm here for.
What I want.
And within minutes he says, well, I've got,
I've got kids as young as 11 years old.
As we said, we none of us heard of this
movie, and you would have only heard of
this movie if you are a regular among
church groups or you regularly watch
Fox News or you follow right-wing personality
like Ben Shapiro and Jordan Peterson and the
like or you are a QAnon conspiracy theorist
or part of the so-called freedom movements.
This movie is a powerful movie, that is showing
you the truth of what has happened - what
is happening - and what will continue to
happen if we don't do anything about this.
And the media had that to say?
They're showing their true colors.
You need to stop supporting these kind of people.
There are powerful people behind the
scenes controlling certain media groups.
Certain people in Hollywood.
And they don't want you to know the truth.
And you know, Tim spoke to the Senate years ago.
Watch this.
For the last five years, as Chairman
Graham mentioned, I served as the
founder and CEO of the anti-trafficking
organization Operation Underground Railroad
working hand in hand with law enforcement in 20
countries including 22 states in this country.
Operation Underground Railroad
has rescued over 2,000 victims
and assisted in the arrest of over
1,000 traffickers and pedophiles.
Much of my work has been
based on simple economics.
The United States is one of the
highest if not the highest consumers
of child pornography in the world.
We are the demand for child sex.
As such, traffickers around the world seek to
bring children to the United States where they
can sell them for sex and make a lot of money.
My number one personal and professional goal
has been to keep these children out of the
hands of these sick American pedophiles.
I want to share one case in
which we failed to do this.
The victim was a foreign-born child
around 12 years old who we will call Lily.
Lily was kidnapped south of the border.
She was then taken along with several
other children her age and smuggled into
the United States, not through a port of
entry but rather through a part of the southern
border without significant barriers or a wall.
Lily's traffickers easily transported
her to New York City where she
was raped between 30 and 40 times a day.
And this is not atypical
at all for a case like this.
She believes that she alone was raped over
20,000 times between the age of 13
and 17, right here in our country.
Shame on them.
Shame on those people who did it.
Shame on those people out there, right now,
who are trying to discredit what happened,
who are trying to discredit this movie.
That's built on truth - on facts.
And you know, three years ago,
Hollywood rejected this movie.
They didn't want you to see this.
Listen to the producer.
Did you expect this kind of response?
It has been a groundswell across America.
I just reacted to what that last two weeks
have been like with your amazing film.
Of course, of course not. I mean we spent eight
years of our lives in putting this movie together
and I never imagined especially when you finish
the film almost three years ago and then you were
knocking doors everywhere and all the experts in
Hollywood told us that this is not a good film for
them, that nobody will go see this film, so after
three years of rejection you have two options:
either you give up or you don't give up and
which you know we choose the second one and after
praying to God for a miracle to happen for this
film, please send an angel to rush with this film.
Angel Studios rescued this film and because of
them, millions of people are seeing this film.
In this 10 days, more than 5 million
people showed up in theaters and I
can't believe that this is happening.
This is like I feel like I'm dreaming.
Evil is working behind the scenes and
you know they've been working in the
entertainment industry for a long time now.
Just look back these last few decades.
Just look at how much the
entertainment industry has changed.
Think about what your kids are watching today
compared to what you watched when you grew up.
It's because through entertainment they
know that they can influence people,
especially young innocent minds as vulnerable.
They want to change what people are thinking
about life itself - what the new normal is.
And you know, there are good people out
there with good values, good morals, that have
great shows but they don't want it out there.
They want to control what people see
so that it can control what they think.
You know, I was very sad because I wanted it
to come out in theaters three years ago and it
was not happening and then maybe a year later
okay this is the time now and nothing happens
and of course I was sad.
My investors were calling
me - Eduardo - what's going on?
A lot of pressure from all my investors.
I have a lot of investors - a lot of
people that believe in this project.
And now I'm responsible - I'm the producer -
I'm calling Alejandro the director and he's
calling me every day - what's going on? what's
going on? and I'm just bleeding because I show
the film to the people and the people cry, the
people, you know, they (give) standing ovations,
but the experts are saying no this is not for us,
so of course you get confused because you don't
know really what do you have in your hands.
But you know what?
Wen you are waking up every day and you
know that you're using your talents - your
projects - to save lives, you know what?
You can stay 20 years - 40 years - for
that one child, because that's
the exercise that I do every day.
I close my eyes every day in the
morning - what if this is my song?
What if my daughter is missing?
What would I do?
I will stop everything that I'm
doing and I will give my life
to find my child. Well, that's my motivation.
I'm waking up every day to fight for children.
To end child trafficking.
I don't want to wait - I don't want to wait for
this tragedy to come to my life for me to wake up.
I want to wake up now.
A lot of you need to wake up right
now and maybe this movie can start
this whole movement because
there are secret societies
and evil is working within them and through
them in big corporations, governments,
school systems, social media
companies, and certain news media.
They didn't want this movie to
get out there in the first place.
And now that it is out there, they can't stop it.
But still, they are trying to - they're trying
to discredit it.
Ask yourself why?
Why don't they want you to see this movie?
I mean, this is the worst kind of evil.
Little children, innocent children.
Ask yourself, why don't they want us to see it?
What are they hiding?
Media - Hollywood - those secret societies.
Watch this.
Elijah Wood - shocking allegations against the
entertainment industry in a new interview with the
Sunday Times, the former child star alleges that
pedophilia has been a real issue in Hollywood.
He tells the publication, quote, there are a
lot of vipers in this industry - people who
only have their own interest in mind.
What bums me about these situations
is that the victims can't speak
as loudly as the people in power.
That's the tragedy of attempting to reveal
what is happening to innocent people.
They can be squashed, but their
lives have been irreparably damaged.
But there is Hollywood's other dirty secret
that victimizes the most vulnerable: children.
And someone who's spoken out about
this and is painfully aware is
former child star Corey Feldman.
You freeze - you're in shock.
I mean, children aren't supposed
to handle that sort of stuff.
I can tell you that the number one
problem in Hollywood was and is
and always will be pedophilia.
Nobody talks about pedophilia.
It's the big secret.
And it's widespread?
Oh yeah, I was surrounded by them.
And Jeff asked whether Weinstein's
behavior was an open secret in Hollywood.
I think there was knowledge amongst a
certain group of people - mostly who did
business with Harvey Weinstein - there are
countless women who understood that that's
what happened and there were many people who
said, well, that's just Harvey being Harvey.
How serious is it?
Is it about one person,
one man, or is it a culture?
You and I and even the likes of the people on
the Turner Classic movies understand that the idea
of the casting couch that existed in Hollywood is
the part of both myth and concrete reality.
They would go to the auditions and so forth
to try to pick the ones that they wanted.
At one point, he said, uh you know what,
why don't you just take off your clothes.
Take off your clothes and let me see
what you look like.
You've their faces.
One alleged victim had roles in What's
Eating Gilbert Grape and The Apostle.
Another is an aspiring musician who was
violated when he was just 11 years old.
Meet Evan Hensing.
He is just one of
five telling their stories in
the documentary An Open Secret.
The 21 year old says he was abused for five years
by his manager Marty Weiss, who was convicted for
his sex crimes on Evan in 2012.
Do you remember that first time?
Yeah, yeah, I do.
What happened?
We went to the park and we played basketball
so it was that night he touched me.
At 11, I didn't know it was improper.
It just didn't make any sense to me.
But Evan may not be the only one.
The manager also allegedly abused
the late Corey Haim and Corey Feldman.
Feldman told us it didn't end there.
When I look back at a picture of when I was
15 years old and I was surrounded by five men
and every one of those men in that photograph
is a pedophile, that's a pretty big problem.
I was molested and I said
yes, I allowed it to happen.
But I was a child.
I was told that this is
everyday business and he made me feel like
I have to do that in order to get any job.
He was just saying this
was common in the industry.
He said, oh, if you have sex with me
then we'll go to Sea World the next day.
When did you finally decide
I have to tell someone?
At 18.
I tape recorded an hour-long conversation and
I asked him straightforward why did you abuse me?
And how did he respond?
He responded and said that you
were coming on to me at 12.
There is an evil sickness within these secret
societies working within them and through them.
They come straight from the devil, who wants to
cause as much pain and suffering in this
temporary world while he still has time.
These people, they worship
the devil, their father.
[John 8:44]
You know, my heart goes out to all
the victims, especially the children.
Even your children - being brainwashed in
schools, through the media and through the
entertainment - the things they watch -
and the games they play. And also these
children who are being trafficked - millions
of them - these are innocent little children.
This is sick.
This is evil.
Pure evil.
And you know, these pedophiles are smiling because
a lot of people out there - part of the media -
Hollywood - are trying to discredit this movie
and they're laughing.
Tim Ballard joins me now.
So Tim, why is the media hating this movie?
You know, I can't understand it.
The film was made - produced - written
- like five years - six years ago.
Way before anyone heard the name QAnon.
I still don't even know what QAnon is.
In the meantime, they're trying to connect it
to some conspiracy, when in fact, like you said,
this is a true story.
These are real kids.
I mean I'm these kids are my
friends they're young adults now.
The ones who are rescued, they're going
to come out soon and tell their story.
It's going to be very awkward when the mainstream
media comes after these kids next and accuses
them of being part of some conspiracy when in
fact they were rescued from a life of rape.
It's the most bizarre thing I've
ever seen in the media perhaps.
I mean this publication says the Sound of
Freedom is a superhero movie for dads with
brain worms and that it fetishizes
the torture of its child victims.
Is that what the movie does?
It absolutely does not do that.
It tells a story based in truth and you
know what I think is happening, Jesse,
I think that the left and these media outlets -
they don't want to have a discussion that this
film is going to compel a discussion about why
85,000 children showed up unaccompanied at the
border and got released into the interior of a
country that is the highest consuming country
for child exploitation material on the planet.
They don't want to talk about why the same
publications are pushing an agenda to change the
word pedophile to minor attracted persons in order
to normalize sexual activity with children.
I think that's what they're trying to avoid.
And they know this film's gonna shine
a light on all of the things - all
the atrocities happening in children and so
they have to discredit it by lying about it.
These people are evil.
No wonder they're trying to spread
lies to discredit this movie.
But you know what?
They cannot stop God.
You know, God is light and He
shines His light on darkness.
On the evil.
And it is coming to light.
And look what He did through Tim Ballard.
It is amazing, saving these children.
Listen to what the producer said.
You know, you know what I think?
Why this is touching so many hearts?
Because there's millions of
people praying for this film.
I believe in the power of prayer and a
lot of people are praying for this film
so this film can touch hearts so to speak.
This movie can put pressure in government
so government once and for all - I hope that
they will do something because they have the
power to end this. Especially in America, you
have the most powerful country in the world.
You have the money, the technology,
the army, the intelligence.
Everything.
How come we don't finish this problem?
Because it's not a priority.
You know, we need to support and
pray for projects like this.
They need our help.
So share it, far and wide, with everyone and
you can pay it forward if you have the money,
then you can pay it forward so that other
people can go and watch it so that they can
go and claim their free ticket online.
We need to overcome evil with good.
We need your help because there will always
be people - evil - who want to stop this.
For example, the Washington Post said
"QAnon and the Sound of Freedom both
rely on tired Hollywood tropes".
And Forbes said "The Adrenochrome
Conspiracy Theory pushed by the
Sound of Freedom star explained.
You know, it's the same thing over and over.
They use the same things whenever
you want to speak the truth.
They label you, or oh, it's a conspiracy theory.
And aren't you getting tired of this?
Here is Tim Ballard's own response.
If the truth of human trafficking and child
trafficking and child exploitation were to be
brought to bear, brought to light, then they
would have to have a debate, a discussion,
that they don't want to have about again these
policies around sexualizing children or allowing
children to consent at a young age to do anything
and everything which would eventually include
being, you know, identifying as an adult,
perhaps, and having sex with pedophiles.
I hunt pedophiles.
I've been hunting them for 20 years and
they are watching this and they're salivating.
They are happy that Rolling Stone and the
Guardian are ripping on a movie that exposes them.
So I don't like the fact that these media outlets
are, in fact, wittingly or unwittingly running
interference for human traffickers and pedophiles.
That's ridiculous, that's ridiculous you know?
They should apologize to all these
kids who were rescued.
They should apologize to them
and they should apologize to all these people
who rescued their lives to tell their story.
I mean, it's amazing.
I mean, what can I say, you know?
I'm just so grateful.
These guys are lying but somehow because of their
lies people are waking up so they're helping us.
I mean, the numbers are showing up that you know,
we're doing good so whatever they're doing hey
keep doing because of your lies people who love
truth now they're responding but this but you
know they should apologize because it's not fair.
These guys are lying.
These are the mainstream liberal
media, who don't care about children.
They don't care about saving children,
they don't care about anything.
They care about just themselves,
and perhaps maybe some of them, I don't know, I
don't have the evidence, but it's really weird.
Suspicious.
That someone doesn't
want this film to be seen by many.
A film that is designed to save
children and they're blocking?
Maybe they're involving the crime.
Maybe they are the pedophiles.
Maybe these are the guys who are hurting
these children, I don't know.
You know, go figure.
You need to be very careful and not listen just
blindly and follow what the media is saying.
And what celebrities are saying in Hollywood.
They are controlled by people
so they're just spewing lies.
You need to understand this, just because they're
celebrities doesn't mean that they have some
special knowledge or there's something special.
They're just human beings like you and me.
You need to follow the truth and stick
to the truth because it is only
the truth that will set you free.
And if you know the truth it is easy to
discern when someone is telling a lie,
trying to control how you view the world.
The devil is working hard behind the scenes.
[1 Peter 5:8]
Now, the devil and his demons
are in this temporary world.
And they're doing their best
to bring out the most evil acts
of us human beings because of our sinful flesh.
So they bring the worst of our sinful flesh out.
And it causes so much pain and suffering.
And yes, they are in the world and they are
going to do what they're gonna do, but that
doesn't mean that you should just sit back and
do nothing because then evil will take over.
When good men like you and me sit
in our comfort zones and do nothing.
God is looking for good men and women to stand
up to say, here I am, use me to shine light on
darkness, on evil, to overcome evil with good.
He is looking for people who will do it through
the Spirit because we know if we're acting through
the Spirit, then we'll act within the will of God
and we will have no fear because the word of God
says that He has not given us a spirit of fear,
but of power, of love, and self-control.
And that is what Tim did - he raised his hand
and he overcame evil with good.
And I want you to listen to
this - to what Jim Caviezel said on the
Daily Wire while he sat next to Tim.
And one of the things that hit me with the
screenplay was it was very biblical to me.
In the fact, where you have a guy that literally
goes and finds this little boy and the little boy
just asks him from Homeland Security asks him,
hey, you know, gets information but
the little boy asks him, hey, will you
save my sister and he has to make a decision.
And that's where we are as a country right now.
Can you - what kind of decision
would you make if God came to you?
We ask God and pray all the time
but God does come to us and ask us
here it is - what are you going to do about it?
And Tim, essentially with the help of his wife,
sold everything he had to go
and find this little girl.
And I know there are many stories in
the Bible about stories like this.
They're rare. This Ms. Rojas. I keep
bringing this up. Ms. Rojas on April 26th
give sworn testimony, okay, and from the
House committees and says that we are 850,000
children have gone missing right? 850,000.
Next day in the media - nothing.
And this continually happens all the time.
Why does that continue to happen?
And you feel like there's some sort
of criminal syndicate going on here?
And I'm praying that a lot of these guys
are in these three letter agencies - a lot
of these young guys that know a lot - will
come forward and start telling the truth.
And this film has the power
that you feel in your heart, OK?
That I'm not afraid of evil.
I'm not afraid of evil anymore.
I'm gonna go out.
I'm gonna do the right thing,
come hell or high water.
Now, there is a fight between good and evil.
And there is a line being drawn in the sand
that is becoming more clear every day.
And I'm gonna say something that's going
to be shocking to you, but I need you to listen.
Because evil is out there working in the world.
But it might also be working in you.
If you watch pornography, hear me out.
You might not have a sex slave but
the porn industry does use sex slaves.
A lot of them underage.
And if you continue to watch porn,
you are helping these people -
evil people - to stay in business.
According to humantraffickingsearch.org,
traffickers can sell sexual photos of the woman
in addition to forcing them into prostitution at
a great financial gain and the younger the girls,
the more expensive the photos, making the
underground child pornography industry one of
the most lucrative markets for sex traffickers.
According to fightthenewdrug.org, by some
estimates, 4.8 million people are trapped
or forced into sexual exploitation globally.
More than one in five victims
of sex trafficking are children.
Of domestic minor trafficking victims who had been
forced into porn production, the average age they
began being filmed was 12.8 years old.
Man, you know I'm shaking here.
This is just pure evil.
In one survey, 63 percent
of underage sex trafficking victims said
they had been advertised or sold online.
Do you get it?
It's about demand and supply.
If there's no demand, there'll be no supply.
If there are millions of people being trafficked
and there are millions of people who want
them to be trafficked - who want to have
sex slaves - this is disgusting.
Think about how many evil people
there really are in the world.
And the devil is laughing.
Sick pedophiles and people
looking at porn as well.
You think there's no connection?
Of course there is.
And then you know, I can't believe
that there are so many people out there
who want to look at little kids
naked, molest them and rape them.
It is disgusting.
It is sick.
There is a sickness within humans
and it is called a fleshly nature.
And some have given themselves over to their
fleshly desire, so much so, that they've
seared with a hot iron their conscience
so they don't even care about it anymore.
They don't care about these
innocent little children.
[1 Timothy 4:1]
[Romans 1:28]
These people in powerful positions want to
hide their sin where it festers and grows.
And it is time that you shine
your light and expose them.
And if there are people who are struggling with
porn addiction, then please watch this video here,
and it will definitely help you out.
And if you are curious about how these
evil people want to control the world and are
controlling the world, then watch this video here.
And I'll see you there.
And always remember, that life is short.
So don't waste yours.
Where you live in darkness or
you're sitting on the sidelines.
Cheers guys.
[Ephesians 5:11]